SENATE IN KANSAS.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE STORY ON THE
POLITICAL FRONT.
ON THE IRAN STRIKE AND TESTIFIED
TONIGHT AND THAT SHE WILL TRY TO
PRESIDENT DEL MICHAEL LIMIT
WHERE POWER AND HE SAYS THE TWIT
WHERE POWER AND HE SAYS THE TWIR
POSTS ARE ALL THEY NEED.
THAT BATTLE COULD EVENTUALLY END
NOW.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO WORK, THE
CONSTITUTION HAS CONFLICTING
MESSAGES.
ARTICLE TWO SECTION TWO STATES
"THE PRESIDENT SHALL BE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THE ARMY
AND NAVY OF THE UNITED STATES."
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF HAS
LIMITS AND ARTICLE ONE AND
SECTION 8 SAYS "CONGRESS ALONE
HAS THE POWER TO DECLARE WAR."
AS TENSIONS WITH IRAN REACH A
BOILING POINT, THE
INTERPRETATIONS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S POWER IS UP FOR
DEBATE IN THE CITY THAT
RELATIVES THE TERM.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY
AUTHORITY HE NEEDED AS COMMANDER
IN CHIEF TO DO THE RIGHT
DECISION BECAUSE AMERICAN LIVES
WERE AT STAKE.
>> PRESIDENT SAID I HAD 52
TARGETS ON MICHAEL AFTER THEM, I
MIGHT DO IT DISPROPORTIONALLY I
MIGHT GO AFTER CULTURAL SITES
AND THAT IS WAR.
IF THAT IS NOT A RESPONSE TO A
IMMINENT THREAT.
>> YESTERDAY, PRESIDENT PUT OUT
THIS TWEET ANNOUNCING THAT HIS
POTENTIAL PLAN TO STRIKE AROUND.
OPEN TO MIKE "SEARCH
LEGAL REQUIRE IS NOT REQUIRED."
SCOTT ANDERSON SERVED UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND WAS THE
ADVISOR IN BAGHDAD.
>> HE COORDINATED AT ALL WITH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
OF THE ENTIRE AND MOST RATIONS
HAVE GENERALLY DONE SO TO SOME
EXTENT.
OF >> ANDERSON SAID THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM STILL
HAVE THE UPPER HAND IN MANY
SITUATIONS.
>> THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH HAS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF DISCRETION AND
PRACTICALLY AND HOW THEY
INTERPRETED BOTH THE OWN
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY AND
STATUTES THAT CONGRESS MIGHT
PASS TO GIVE IT ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY FOR MILITARY FORCE.
>> A WORLD WAR II MARKS THE LAST
TIME CONGRESS OFFICIALLY
DECLARED WAR.
IN 1973, CONGRESS PASSED THE WAR
POWERS RESOLUTION WHICH REQUIRES
THE PRESIDENT TO NOTIFY CONGRESS
WITHIN 48 HOURS OF SENDING
TROOPS INTO HOSTILE TERRITORY.
FOLLOWING THE 9/11 ATTACKS,
CONGRESS PASSED THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR USE OF
MILITARY FORCE GIVING THE
PRESIDENT BROAD AUTHORITY IN
SPECIFIC CASES.
THE AUMF AS IT'S KNOWN, USED 41
TIMES IN 18 COUNTRIES.
THE SUPREME COURT NEVER RAILED
DIRECTLY ON THE PRESIDENTS
WORKHORSE BEFORE AND LEGAL
EXPERTS SAY THAT WAS BY THE SIGN
TO KEEP HIM OUT OF THE FIGHT AND